they are [ __ ] back let's see here
what the [ __ ] are we doing now dampen
spirits oh [ __ ] alright seconds in if I
got such as you know I don't take no for
an answer haha [ __ ] i get out of here
yes wait nothing even there we go that's
there that's better say something should
I bashas meal I joined up now Oakland
[ __ ] money man for mock me great
billions rob caroline okay guy shits
herself one pull off it when i started
out in this business I didn't mean to
imply i'm with my lock-picking attitude
that was a min yeah yeah yeah okay d
south shetty this [ __ ] [ __ ] gonna
be talking all day after that problem I
don't know kneeling Shay said already
knew delvin i asked if i could join up
and I was like hey lockpick lockpick not
only [ __ ] garlic any lock bags what
is that the [ __ ] that man ok lockpick
the STA got better things to do this
better be important so you have better
things to do the disturb me i need
locked x this is a [ __ ] vehicle i
thought i could get some here if i cant
that's okay just tell me
okay kill chest Bach pick there we go ok
let Peter right enough [ __ ] go it was
more in here oh [ __ ] yeah I get that so
I whatever name you want who shed that's
like that'sthat's iron sword
ok let's do this okay yeah that's
[ __ ] ass Kosta with my ex-wife mm ah
i got places a day who's that nutjob
[ __ ] weird
okay i'm going to the riches house
apparently we wait to [ __ ] daytime
okay good beneath that great sure sure
I'm a dirty beggar why would you want to
even speak uh-huh I don't have any
business of you so get out of my face
Wow well [ __ ] [ __ ] so you're the
one hmm you don't look so impressive
thanks [ __ ] is that confidence up you
have to understand it's been a lot face
all i care about his cause and effect
did the job get done and was it done
correctly there's no head to the bannard
mare and white rum and look for malice
macchia I can fill you in on all the
details the next form a [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
kind of [ __ ] talkative ok I had the
white run it's out of here in it tagging
[Music]
okay [ __ ] need a ride where do you want
to go by trot climbing back and we'll be
off you ever met wanted in a package
it's [ __ ] animals I never met at
coogee that liked I'll be honest with
you ok ok wait I've been here
that guys seriously need to do some
[ __ ] cardio or salsa yeah so we're
that crazy king is no shadows dude
mm-hmm I bet that's a [ __ ] my [ __ ]
yeah daddy how are you the banners mer
there's a horse for the vagina didn't
now let me know if you want anything if
you need a simple i give am going on
with Scott I say I say can't a man drink
in peace I'm going to keep this rotting
brews owner sad yarn is about to hold it
tasting for white runs captain of the
guard and we're going to no no that's
the beauty the meaner he has quite a
pest problem and the whole city knows
about it pest poison and me yeah I know
you're going to happen by and lend poor
old he's going to give you the poison to
use on the test but you're also going to
dump it into the brewing maven and I
spent weeks planning this now get going
before sub yarn grows a brain and hires
someone else to do the dirty work okay
you got it sister I want to ask
questions you know as long as I get paid
it's all I care about and anything else
is above my pay grade let's get a scrim
oh hey check-ins hi yep Matt here where
the [ __ ] I'm gone [ __ ] a why is it so
far away this is what the [ __ ]
companions were
[Music]
why is it always [ __ ] so dark
[ __ ] baby ya [ __ ] darkish [ __ ]
[ __ ] daughter [ __ ] ow ow ow ow so I
was [ __ ] Dyke a chef hey hey what the
[ __ ] what are you gawking at are you
kidding I'm supposed to be holding it if
he sees the Meadery in this state oh I
hope you're not expecting to get paid
until the job's done well that's not how
I operate so forget well that's not how
I your [ __ ] careful Janet my only
demand is that these vermin are
permanently eliminated be I bought some
poison I was going to have my if you
plant this in the vermin's next it
should stop them from don't come back
until every one of those things are dead
okay you got it sister yeah what wait up
i set up eyes up ok dispatch over here
unless I can get in there [ __ ] I don't
know that's the way lock then just
[ __ ] terrible
hmm
yes
that
okay i guess a poisonous [ __ ] while
where I guys put the poison [ __ ]
I poison oh yeah you got that right
great what the [ __ ] what's it what's it
aiming to me
hmm mad
feeltune hear some good [ __ ] some good
[ __ ] out man I'll admit okay I gotta
dump this [ __ ] in there go over here
perfect
okay and i also got a car has a pest
problem I that's how many gone there
look [ __ ] okay so I got to go in here
all right yeah I know I don't ask any
questions you know the boss
Hey Wow [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh down here no
wonder you got a pen stop you got a
[ __ ] war tech oh [ __ ] who is this
[ __ ] if you got more than a pest
problem sure please put killing homeless
people live another
someone there okay honey [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] dying
I don't know who that [ __ ] was but
Jesus [ __ ] a what else I've lost that
see I don't know what the [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] weird
alright let's see that do this then I
have to pursue Chapel out of that Jesus
where's that [ __ ] out what's something
we did well it's about time I had to
you'll just have to wait until after the
captain's finished I suppose you can
wait to run the commander of the guard
here in Whiterun that's a tasting Sam
Riley well sub yarn now that you've
taken care of your little pest problem
how about I get a taste to some of your
need oh good tell my lord it's my finest
brew tea I call it hunting brew reserve
I think you'll find it quite pleasing to
your palate oh come now this is me not
some wine to be sipped and savored
yeah [ __ ] die by the what what's in
this I I don't know what's wrong you
assured me this place is clean I'll see
see to it that you remain in irons for
the rest of your days Cat Cat please I
don't understand silence idiot I should
have known better to trust this place
after it's been riddled with bill I beg
you please this is not what it seems you
you're in charge here until I can sort
this all out it will be my pleasure and
you you're coming with me to dragons
reach mm-hmm see how quickly your memory
clears in a city prison now move look I
assure you this is all just a huge
misunderstanding I said smooth farewell
I looking at me I like when they look at
me and heard even a scratch of the door
have you done it I don't think that
could have gone any so maven wants to
humped up you're welcome to take a look
around sub yarns off here this should
help oh I thought it would be better to
leave some of the details out of our
besides you've done maven a favor
getting rid of him and saved me from
wasting cold start changing it over to
the blackbriar meatery West soon she's
put me in charge if you're in the area
you ever need anything sensed you just
uh huh I can't believe that world that's
I spend out I can't believe that route
though
I used to be an adventurer like you then
I took an arrow in the knee okay I'm
kind of silent partner rorish there's a
nice enough is a habit the boring hotel
talking in here am i leaving them Oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can't believe upstairs
work so not thank you
is that MMA I need [ __ ] figure that's
for sure Krak des mm-hmm oh [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is that that day
okay I can't believe that worked
remember to put in a good word Matt
where the [ __ ] that I gotta go now
fast travel is a craft [ __ ] this is my
first wife I've never seen the old said
about anything city really good I trust
you have good news doesn't tell me much
the only thing that could identify sod
it well whoever you should bring this
intimate there's also the matter of your
payment thank you I believe you'll find
this more than adequate for three
[ __ ] cockatiel man
thank God can [ __ ] see what I'm
that's for sure just stop it down that
they can't say that
word on the street is that for stabbed
yarn found himself in white exactly now
you're beginning maven sent word that
you discovered something else while you
are out there then this is beyond
coincidence first iron goth and now some
yard someone's trying to take us down by
driving a wedge between maven and again
Mercer thinks he knows only you can hang
on in our side he wants to meet with you
right away and if I were you I'd honey
I've never seen him this angry before
thank you